we watch like Lord of the Rings on
Amazon Prime I was like I don't know
what the heck is happening and so I do
this after every movie every show I
pretty much always go to YouTube and I
say ending explained I sometimes didn't
even like a movie and once I actually
watch and they're like look at these
angles look at this storyline look at
this Motif yeah I'm like well I didn't
see that at all we live in a world where
you can make a good living as a Content
DJ as one who curates I'm watching The
Lord of the Rings summary and it's a
rich media experience this guy didn't
create the media but he DJ it CU he's
showing you the trailers and the flips
so if you are passionate and it keeps
you curious you can monetize that
passion